summer bod check making out poolside
check kinda sorta unconfirmed couple
alert check the world isn't ready
Timothy shall May and a Zygon solace
were spotted kissing in Cabo San Lucas
Mexico not expecting that very random
yeah we didn't see this coming but the
pair kicked off their summer by jetting
off to a mid pandemic get away don't
stop living your life and we got to say
Mexico life is looking good for these
two I have a good feeling it will be but
shall amazing Gonzalez were definitely
vibing together at one point the 24 year
old whipped out a guitar in GM tau for
his new lady friend I loved it Salameh
was last in a relationship with Lily
Rose death he's so so great at what he
does he's incredible she's excellent
she's very strong actress the two
reportedly called it quits in April
after more than a year of dating I must
leave you now but it looks like sha'lame
has fully recovered from the break-up so
who is his possible new girlfriend Iza
Gonzalez I'm very writer dying I have
you girl if you need me I'm there
Gonzalez was last linked to actor Luke
Gracie the thirty year old also dated
Josh Duhamel in 2018 was linked to
maluma in 2017 Calvin Harris in 2016 and
Liam Hemsworth in 2013 I love me some
boys the Mexican actress has starred in
bloodshot fast and furious presents
Hobbs and shot and baby driver
et spoke with Gonzalez back in 2018
about her skyrocketing career I had a
conversation with my mom two days ago
she was with me and the sets and the set
of Hobbes and Shaw and I sat down with
her and I looked at her and I said I am
scared and she said what do you mean and
I said I'm just scared that this is
gonna be the end like I'm still a woman
I'm still insecure and I fear you know
like when you're like this is too good
to be true I just I'm so determined and
I always want to do the best job as I
can and such a perfectionist and I'm
like if I don't and I feel like people
are gonna be disappointed in me
and all i care is representing latina
women in a way that they feel proud and
so that is daunting - she looked at me
as she said you know all that matters
baby is to be a good person and continue
to be the loving thoughtful girl that
you are and that will bring things to
your life
[Music]